the Air Force review of mistakes that
allowed the Texas church gunmen to buy
his firearms will be finished within
days Vice President Mike Pence made that
announcement yesterday before meeting
with victims and their families we've
now learned the names of all 26 people
that were killed on Sunday they include
crystal Holcomb three of her children
and crystals unborn baby the family had
nicknamed him Billy Bob
mark Strassmann is at the church in
southern Springs now with the latest on
this story mark good morning I want to
show you something good morning this
long row of crosses 26 in all built by a
man in Chicago
who drove here to put them up these are
all shooting victims people like Joanna
Ward massacred in church on a Sunday
morning and as devastated as this
community is they also realize it could
have been even worse with a warm embrace
Vice President Mike Pence thanked
Stephen Wilford the man who shot at
gunman Devon Kelly Sunday and
interrupted his killing spree standing
in this place is very humbling to me
every American has been inspired by the
heroes of Sutherland Springs the vice
president also promised to work with
Congress to ensure that court marshals
are properly reported Kelly received a
bad conduct discharge in 2014 after his
conviction for domestic violence that
should have barred him from purchasing
firearms but the Air Force never told
the FBI
Ronald Corrigan says he's angry with the
Air Force there will be a day of
reckoning but it's not today Corrigan's
brother Robert a decorated 30 year Air
Force veteran who served two tours in
Afghanistan was killed Sunday along with
his wife shady Cheney was a real
inspiration he loved his wife more than
anything in the world
Tory McCallum lost four family members
I just find solace that they were they
were her sister-in-law Krystal Holcomb
and three nieces and nephews Emily Megan
and Greg Hill there were just so many
babies in there watching that would take
person after person oh it was so
heartbreaking
on Wednesday Apple revealed
investigators have not asked it for help
unlock
the gunman's cellphone had they done so
in the first 48 hours the company would
have suggested using the gunman's
fingerprints on the touch ID feature no
family suffered more loss than the
Holcomb's there are nine crosses for
them representing three generations of
the family
this is crystal Holcomb she was pregnant
and the small cross right here it
represents her unborn child charlie
thanks barb